Welcome back everyone Sony and Marvel just
made some big Spider-Man 4 announcements this
week about what's going on during the movie which
characters are coming back what's changing because
of Doctor Strange's spell in the MCU and some
of the spider-verse characters coming into the
live action movies so we'll break it all down
we all theorize about spider-verse coming into
live action if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos they'll start
releasing more Spider-Man 4 details soon the movie
will come out during Marvel Phase 5 in 2025. the
reason they didn't have it on the Marvel Phase 5
schedule revealed at Comic-Con last year it's just
because they hadn't finalized the details with Tom
Holland and Sony yet typically the Marvel people
Kevin feige lets Sony make most of the initial
release date announcements about the Spider-Man
movies Sony's a much bigger part of the actual
marketing Marvel mostly just handles the creative
like the actual writing the filming of the movie
Sony gets to make most of those big announcements
the Sony people are usually the ones that give
away some of the biggest secrets about the movie
too that's how we started getting details about
Andrew Garfield and Toby Maguire in Spider-Man
no way home because they were coming from Sony
promos that they were releasing not the Marvel
people the reason we got all these new Spider-Man
4 in live action spider-verse details is because
of the Spider-Man across the spider-verse premiere
Amy Pascal is the person at Sony who's in charge
of all these main Tom Holland Spider-Man movies
and the one revealing all these new details like
she's the person in all those Kevin feige memes
that you saw the last several years she's also a
producer on the spider-verse movies and some of
the Spider-Man Venom spin-off movies like she's
on the Venom movies but she didn't have anything
to do with the morbius movie and I don't think she
had anything to do with the Craven movie that's
coming out later this year too at the premiere
they confirm most of the details we'd already
heard about Spider-Man 4 and the new stuff that
she revealed is that Zendaya is coming back as
her version of MJ should be a main character again
despite Doctor Strange's spell and everything that
happened in the Spider-Man no way home ending in
post-credit scenes a lot of people online were
confused by this detail like wait a minute what
does that mean that the ending of Spider-Man no
way home doesn't mean anything now why is she
still a main character director of Peter had all
memory of their past together erased from her mind
to protect her like literally she has no idea that
Peter Parker as a person exists in the movie Just
because they couldn't think of a way fast enough
to fix the tears in the Multiverse without erasing
all knowledge of him from everyone's Minds so
bring her back in the story is a main kind of
walks that twist back just slowly it means that
they'll continue being around each other whether
he plans to be around her or not she'll just
continue to be part of his orbit while he's
trying to be Spider-Man and be Peter Parker and
go to college during the day early theory is that
he'll probably wind up having to save her a couple
of times and he'll be around her during the day
and things between them will play out similarly to
the way they did before where she starts to notice
weird inconsistencies and coincidences and she
figures out that he is Spider-Man all by herself
again originally the idea during Spider-Man no
way home like the whole reason for Dr stranger's
spells in the first place is because they were all
trying to get into MIT and at the end the movie
both she and Ned got into MIT so you'd think that
they would go to Cambridge the only way to explain
her being a main character again because the movie
is going to take place in the New York City area
would be if she loses any chance of a scholarship
to MIT and thus can't afford to pay tuition it has
to go to a local New York City College because
that's a pretty common story there are a lot of
my friends in real life that had that problem too
like really smart people that got into Ivy League
colleges but just couldn't pay the massive massive
tuition some somebody bring back Norman Osborne
tell him to pay for everybody's College tuition
Peter was getting his GED at the end of the movie
because all memory of him was erased so it's like
he never attended school so that's why he had to
get the GED in the first place and he'll use that
to get into a local New York City College like
the comics and like the Tobey Maguire Spider-Man
movies early theory is that Zendaya winds up going
to college at Empire State or wherever he winds
up going to college in the New York City area
and that's why they're around each other so much
when he's Peter Parker and as he starts fighting
the villains in his movie and doing things as
Spider-Man as well she just starts to notice
weird inconsistencies and coincidences and like
I said things play out like they did in the first
movie and she just figures it out on her own like
oh you're a version of Spider-Man the other big
news is from Kevin feige and he revealed that the
plot of Daredevil born again will figure heavily
into the events of Spider-Man 4. I have a strong
feeling that and I've said this since I started
the Netflix show so this is not everything
eventually I'm gonna kick Spider-Man's ass
cannot wait to see Daredevil and Spider-Man
team up to fight Kingpin and for Kingpin to
try and squish him some Spider-Man they're gonna
be filming the series all this year all the way to
December so we're gonna get a bunch more scenes
much more of them talking about new characters
and connecting with the upcoming Marvel movies of
course I will do videos for everything and I will
do videos for all the episodes when they start
releasing them there will be 18 episodes total
in season one but they are going to break the
season I believe into two halves like there'll
be two Coors if you watch anime they do that all
the time like season one part one and season one
part two but Vincent D'Onofrio recently explained
they are developing season two so there will be
multiple seasons of the show in addition to these
18 episodes that they're currently filming the
new scenes that they're filming also help set up
what's going to be happening during the events of
Spider-Man 4 so I'll explain how that all fits
together the events of Spider-Man 4 will take
place after Daredevil season 1 and the whole idea
is that he becomes mayor of New York City during
the events or at the beginning of Daredevil Born
Again In what they're doing is setting up sort
of a dark rain era in Marvel Phase 5 where the
villains start to take over and Kingpin is just
the version of Thunderbolt Ross basically in New
York City like Thunderbolt Ross becomes president
of the United States Kingpin becomes mayor of
New York City and rules New York City to make
a defender's pun with an iron fist it's meant to
be based on the comic book run that did a similar
type of story and during that he took a very
anti-vigilante stance and used that to go after
people like Spider-Man people like Daredevil who
he forced to work for him as City prosecutor and
people like Punisher for instance who we know is
coming back during Daredevil Port again Kingpin
isn't meant to be the main villain of Spider-Man
4. he'll just be doing his thing trying to get
rid of Vigilantes like Spider-Man or calling
Spider-Man a vigilante technically is a hero
but he's kind of like a vigilante like Daredevil
so Spider-Man will be dealing with that like
he'll be on the outs with the law because he'll be
coming after him trying to get rid of Vigilantes
while he's also trying to defeat the regular
villains in the movie it's a very Spider-Man
very Daredevil type of problem that have like
how do you save everyone when everyone thinks
that you're the bad guy when technically that's
not true like how do you prove that you are the
good guy it all plays into the whole idea that
they're taking Spider-Man 4 in a more friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man direction away from all
the Iron Man high-level Avengers stuff but he will
still be in Avengers 5 Kang Dynasty and Secret
Wars and all that big stuff too it's just that
they're taking the character back to a more comic
book original Spider-Man type of territory less
Tech based Spider-Man really good examples of that
were Toby Maguire Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield's
versions of Spider-Man they also recently revealed
that they're making a live-action Miles Morales
movie like hot off the presses live-action Miles
Morales and a spider Gwen spin-off movie with
hailee steinfeld's version of the character there
have been Rumors in the past that they were gonna
do live action Miles Morales in the MCU during
Spider-Man 4 because the apartment that he moves
into has Hispanic neighbors so people were like
wait a minute is that Miles Morales family that
just lives in his building with him we already
know a version of Miles Morales exists in the MC
you during the movie Spider-Man across the
spider-verse MCU Aaron Davis also shows up
in Spider-Man 2099's prison he had just become
the prowler during Spider-Man homecoming so it
was like in the time since then he started
wearing the prowler armor there was also
a deleted scene during Spider-Man homecoming
where he specifically mentions Miles Morales
I hate this dude man yeah sorry miles
I'm not gonna make it yeah I'm just stuck
um but I'm just excited for us to introduce
miles into our own Universe one day I think
that's going to be really cool should be wild
yeah that should be a while that all took place
well before Avengers Infinity war in the snap and
there were a lot of theories that they just used
the five-year time Jump to age that version
of Miles Morales up a little bit faster now
shamik Moore who also plays Miles Morales in the
spider-verse movies said that he is trying to get
the job as the live-action version of Miles
Morales like I already play a version of him
and he's in his late 20s so he's a little bit
older but it wouldn't be hard for them to play
him a little bit younger I manifested this so what
are we manifesting now live action that's what I'm
saying it was literally my next question I was
like it's I think it's time to make the jump I
think you're the one to do it thank you so much
that means a lot let's hope let's let's let's
keep pushing forward we're campaigning one step at
a time I saw shmik you said that if they do live
action Miles Morales which I think the writing's
on the wall it's gonna happen at some point
you want to do it right uh do I want to
do it absolutely hell yeah so if they
wanted to do spider Gwen and Jessica Drew
in live action would you guys be game I
old they want miles to be in this new live-action
movie because in the spider-verse movies right
now he's only about 16 years old so it would be
a little bit harder for shamik Moore to play 16
years old I don't know if his comments are meant
to be a misdirect and they're already planning to
use him as the live-action version or if they've
already planned on casting a completely different
actor because during Spider-Man across the
spider-verse they mix so many live-action
versions of Spider-Man into the movie in related
characters like MCU Prowler it supports the theory
that some of the spider-verse versions of the
characters will just transition into live action
for Avengers Secret Wars cameos they'll reveal
more about the live-action Miles Morales movie
next year after Spider-Man beyond the spiderverse
comes out so it'll be a little while before you
figure all that stuff out the spider Gwen movie
is meant to be an animated spin-off so literally
it's just going to be the exact same character
different Adventure they didn't give a release
date I think it'll probably wind up being 20
25 or a little bit later not that long and
speaking of live-action crossover because
she plays Kate Bishop she was also talking
got her version of Kate Bishop meeting the
live-action version of her spider Gwen let
me know in the comments though what do you want
them to do with the live action version of Miles
Morales because they need a version of Spider-Man
for all these Sinister Six spin-offs that they're
developing like in the morbius post-credits scene
they talk about a version of Spider-Man they're
mostly talking about Tom Hall and Spider-Man
but they need a version of Spider-Man for them
to fight in those Sony spin-off movies still kind
of hoping that that winds up being Andrew Garfield
but we'll see congratulations PB James you're
the giveaway winner from my last Marvel video
please email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details everyone click
here for my Spider-Man across the spider-verse
ending post credit scene video and click here
for my full breakdown in Easter eggs for the
entire movie I'll update the link as soon as I
post that thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!